Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in
the book of fasting
which we started actually at the
beginning of Ramadan and here we are
Ramadan is over and we are continuing
in the book of fasting hopefully to
continue fasting throughout the year
we have reached the chapter regarding
fasting that is optional optional
fasting
And there are a number of sun with
respect to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's teachings
that he either encouraged or allowed be
fasted.
And conversely, there are a number of
days, there are a number of times in
which he prohibited that a person fast.
And that is what the next two chapters
will be dealing with inshallah.
These are pretty straightforward
chapters. So we will discuss them
inshallah
in their order and we will discuss
them in relative
brevity.
He says, "The messenger of Allah
has encouraged
that a person fast the following days."
He says
the first he mentions is six days of the
month of Shaw. Of course, he begins with
this because
this is right after the month of
Ramadan. Shaw is the 10th month in the
order of the Islamic lunar calendar. And
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam highly encouraged that a person
fast
six days of the month of Sha following
his fast of the month of Ramadan
Ramadan.
This narration is collected by Muslim
or
Abuani.
Abu Aubsi narrates that the messenger of
Allah sallall.aii Wasam
said, "Whoever fasts the month of
Ramadan and then follows it up with six
days from the month of Sha, it will be
as
if he fasted the entire year
meaning the year."
And this narration
is pretty wellnown or at least its
meaning is well known.
And
if we look at the wording of the
narration, what is the best way to fast
the six days of Shaw? The wording of the
narration, listen to the words. Whoever
fasts the month of Ramadan
and then
Thank you, sir. You're such a gentleman.
Whoever fasts, I'm not fasting. Whoever
fasts the month of Ramadan
and then follows that fasting by fasting
six days of Sha,
it will be as as if he has fasted the
entirety of the year.
So if we were to stick to the most
apparent wording of the narration,
what the narration definitely means is
for a person to fast all of Ramadan and
then the immediate six following days of
Shaw. However, we know that that is not
permissible.
What do you mean? Well, it is as it will
as it will come up impermissible to fast
on the day of Eid and the day of Eid is
which day?
The first of Shaw. So
definitely that is not included in the
generality of the narration. Okay. So
whoever fasts Ramadan and then the
following six days after Eid then we
understand the narration to mean that
and this is what the scholars
agree upon is the best way to do this
sunnah.
However,
what is permissible?
What is acceptable?
For instance, let's say a person doesn't
fast from the 2nd of Shaw to the seventh
of Shaw. Let's say a person fasts a
couple days of Shaw here, a couple
there. Collectively, they are six.
Does this person have to fast them in
sequential order uninterrupted?
The correct opinion? No.
Because the prophet says
and then follows it up with six days
from
notice the wording here. There is
so and then follows it up with six days
from Sha. Any six days, that's what's
apparent. Any six days. It could be the
2nd and the 4th and the 10th and the
12th and the 14th and the 21st and the
it it doesn't matter as long as they are
considered to be six days from the month
of Shawet. This person has correctly
correctly fallen into the meaning
of the narration.
The real difference is
this the statement of whoever fasts
Ramadan and then
let's say a person missed some days from
Ramadan.
Say they have to make some days up from
Do they begin with making their days up
or do they begin with fasting the days
of Sha?
They begin with making the days up.
That's what they begin with. That is
most correct. Because fasting the days
of Ramadan,
even if it is, will always be more
virtuous and more pressing
than fasting something that is a ne.
This is obligatory. This is
a ne. If a person dies having not
completed these days of fasting then
this could be problematic. Whereas
shel this is something that is
preferred. This is optional. Second of
all notice how the reward
seems to be predicated. It seems to be
founded on having completed the Ramadan.
Right? So it's as if he is saying
whoever fasts the month of Ramadan and
then builds upon that fast six days of
Sha then it will be as if he has fasted
the entirety of the year. Now each is
written at least how many times? 10. So
we have 30 days of Ramadan presumably
right this would be 300 and then six
days from Sha 60 days you have 360 days
times some scholars have pointed
this out and this means that this is
something that is highly preferred
sometimes
There is an extremism in in applying
the sunnah and sometimes there is an
extremism in avoiding the sunnah. We are
not to turn away from this sunnah
entirely to the point where you never do
this sunnah in your whole life. Never
should there be any sunnah ever
that
comes across your radar that comes
across your knowledge
that you come across that you completely
turn away from even if it is even if it
is preferred that you completely ignore
for the entirety of your life. This
should never happen.
A person will always do the sunnah in
his life even if it's only one time.
Is it better to do it consistently? Of
course. But you'd never want to be a
person who hears the words of the
messenger of Allah and ignores them and
ignores them.
[Silence]
He tells us, "Subhan, oh you who have
believed,
answer the call of Allah. Respond to the
call of Allah and his messenger. If he
calls you to that which will breathe
life into you meaning to any of Allah or
his messenger's calls when the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam encourages
something and you completely ignore it
you acknowledge yes this is of the
sunnah but you never do it in your life
not 10% not 5%
not 20% just completely 0%
this is shameful
there should never ever be a word or a
statement or a sunnah or an action of
your messenger sallall.aii wasallam
except that you have done it at least
once in your lifetime.
At least once in your lifetime,
right? And so
in this narration,
the most complete way to fulfill this
sunnah is that a person fasts the
entirety of Ramadan and then follows it
with six days of Sha for those days to
be consecutive is best.
Now there are those who are extreme in
applying the sunnah which means that
they treat this as if it is obligatory
and they shame other people that do not
do it. This is incorrect. Then there are
those who are extreme in ignoring it
where they don't do it. It's as if it's
as if these words belong to someone
else. They're meant for someone else.
They're never meant for me. These are
two extremes.
The path of Allah is right in the middle
between the two extremes between
between extreme application and extreme
avoidance.
So it is important to do these six days
of sha. It is not obligatory. It is
highly preferred if a person has days to
make up. Making up those days of Ramadan
takes precedence over fasting these six
days of Shaw. If a person fasts these
days of Ramadan
during the month of Shaw, is it counted
as this sunnah? No. Because these are
days of Ramadan. They are days fasted
outside of Ramadan. Yes. But they are
counted as being of the days of Ramadan.
And that's why we treat our making
our makeup fast as we do any day of
Ramadan. An example,
when a person fasts during the day of
Ramadan, is it permissible for him to
break his fast for no reason other than
just wanting to? No. Of course not. But
if a person is fasting an optional fast,
just fasting a day outside of Ramadan,
that's not obligatory. Is it permissible
to break his fast? Is it not to his
discretion? Yeah, it's his discretion.
But if a person is making up a day of
Ramadan,
can he he can he can choose any day he
wants to make it up. But once he commits
to a day, the same rules apply that
apply during the month of Ramadan.
Once a person commits, now you're
fasting in Ramadan. The same rules
apply. It's no longer to a person's
discretion. If they were to break their
fast, they are to cease immediately and
they are to make it up and they have
committed a sin. This is how a person
makes up days of Ramadan. This is not
the situation for fasting six days of
Sha etc. So a person is making up days
that he missed from Ramadan inshaw.
Does it count towards the six days of
Shaw? The answer is no. Because while
these are
physically days of Shaw, they are
legislatively
counted as days of Ramadan.
[Silence]
How are you?